Speaker 1: The former president, Donald Trump,
is freaking out over possible criminal charges
coming his way. And speaking of Liz Cheney, he's
calling out Liz Cheney as being despicable. Trump
completely lost it on his social media platform.
I guess we call it truth. Social truth central.
Yeah, Trump freaks out over possible criminal
charges by blasting war mongering and despicable
human being. Liz Cheney I still do not believe
that Donald Trump is going to be harsh. It's
just an opinion and it's an empirical question. At
some point he will either be charged or he won't.
And I don't know, eventually he'll die. And at
that point we would say, well, he's not going to
be charged. He's it's over. He's not going to be
charged. We will know the answer at some point.
In the interim, my opinion is Trump is not
going to be charged, at least not likely
for anything related to the January six
committee. Although if charges are coming,
I think they're more likely to come from
Georgia and his attempts there to strong arm
his way into getting Georgia's electoral votes.
Speaker 3: I need 11,000 votes. Give me a break.
Speaker 1: So Donald Trump over the 4th of
July weekend took to his truth social platform
with a completely unhinged message, saying,
quote, And I will try to do this in the best,
most accurate way possible, quote, warmongering
and despicable human being. Liz Cheney,
who is hated by the great people of Wyoming,
down 35, keeps saying over and over again that
her fake UN select committee may recommend
criminal charges against the President of
the United States, who got more votes
than any sitting president in history.
Although millions of votes fewer than Joe Biden,
he doesn't mention that even the Dems didn't know
what she was talking about. Why doesn't she press
charges instead against those that cheated on the
election? There's no evidence anyone did or those
that didn't properly protect the Capitol. He went
on to say, Why doesn't the highly partizan UN
Select Committee of political capital t thugs
the same people, all Trump haters and profiteers,
books, speeches, etc. that were involved with
impeachment? Hoax number one. Impeachment Hoax
number two, the no collusion Mueller report and
overall the all caps now greatest witch hunt
in the history of the USA go after the people
who have been rioting, burning down cities, what
city burned down, leading the massive crime wave
and killing many all over the U.S., including
drug and human traffickers? No. Let's get Trump.
Speaker 3: Anywhere. Donald
Trump. Yeah. Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: Trump's worried, Trump's unhinged,
Trump's out of control. That being said,
I really don't think he has much to worry about in
terms of criminal charges now. He also completely
misunderstands how the January six committee
works. He talks about, Well, why don't they
go and press charges against someone else? The
January six committee doesn't press any charges.
The January six committee investigates with the
investigative power that House committees have. If
in their investigation, they uncover potential or.
Evidence. Evidence of criminality. They can make a
referral to the Justice Department, to Attorney
General Merrick Garland, and they may do so now
to Trump's benefit. If you have to say, well, why
is it looking not so bad for Trump? There is no
evidence whatsoever that Attorney General Merrick
Garland has any interest in indicting a former
president. There's just no reason to think that he
is willing to do that. The January six committee
has exposed so much and the Justice Department
has said, well, we're paying attention to the
proceedings. Oh, okay. Well, what do you plan to
do? Are you even willing to do what the evidence
suggests you should do, if indeed that is what
surfaced as well? They're not commenting on that
much. Like I said earlier in the show, I'm seeing
no evidence that Joe Biden is actually going to
run for reelection. I'm seeing no evidence that
the Merrick Garland Justice Department is truly
willing to prosecute a former sitting president.
And so we may see something out of Georgia. The
fact that Trump is going so nuts should be
interpreted not as a sign that he's likely
to be indicted, but as a sign that he has done
things worthy of an indictment. That's the guilty
conscience that I see from Trump. But I don't
actually think he has anything to worry about.
Let me know what you think. We'll have all the
clips and Trump's Truth Social Troth Essential
Posts on The David Pakman Show Instagram
which you can find at David Pakman Show.